hello and welcome you're logged into the
second of 12 very soil nutrient
management webinar sponsored by the
Northeast sustainable research and
education program that are known as
northeast ser and hosted by the Cornell
University Department of Horticulture
and Cornell Cooperative Extension my
name is Cathy heidenreich and I will be
your moderator for this webinar I just
want to remind you I will take a short
tour that if you have questions or
comments you can shut them type them
into the chat box at the bottom of the
screen push the little bubble to enter
those and we'll be sending those on to
the presenter and also you were able to
comment at least visually up above
there's a little man with his hand
raised and there's several options for
communicating up there as well I want to
point out to you that we have added some
materials from Miss Janet Fallon our
speaker today in the files download box
in the bottom right hand corner you'll
see a 2.4 sampling PDF that's for soil
sampling and you're welcome to download
that and have that also we've added over
in the bottom left-hand corner in the
web links box agri one soils lab that's
the lab that janet is with and that will
take you to their website if you haven't
completed the demographics question or
or the educator pretest those are also
available for download and you can
return them to me by email at MCM for at
cornell.edu okay let me introduce our
speaker and we'll get started with
today's webinar
our speaker is Miss Janet Fallon she's a
certified crop adviser with dairy one I
grow one she's a 1976 Cornell grad with
a degree in plant science and she is a
certified crop adviser in the Northeast
region in Pennsylvania she's an active
board member with a Northeast region
certified crop advisor program Janet
work for a growing the crops research
group an egg way farm seed for 26 years
she worked on their manure management
programs vegetable variety trials mulch
management hay and silage additives and
forage and soybean variety development
she joined dairy one at the lab in
Ithaca in 2003 and provides sales and
technical support and she and her
husband reside in Tony New York she has
two grown children a daughter Sarah a
Cornell grad was doing biofuels research
at Arizona State University and a son
Daniel who is a Spanish teacher at
cazenovia Central School in central New
York Janet we're looking forward to
hearing from you there we go well I'm
right here Kathy and thank you very much
i assume i should get started now can
you hear me hello yes absolutely go
ahead go ahead okay just let it wanted
to make sure okay I'd like to thank the
the group for inviting me to participate
in the soil management for Barry crops
webinar and today the topic will be
specifically on sampling procedures in
soil test options I would like to give
you just a little bit more background
though about dairy one in the
relationship that we have with Cornell
and agri one some of you probably know
who we are and just in case you don't
were many of you might know us as the
former dairy herd improvement
association we do milk testing and
record services for dairy dairy farmers
throughout the Northeast we also provide
herd management software and
installation services I work in the part
of the business that deals with forage
analysis were probably one of the
biggest forged labs in the US we we
cover all 50 states and 37 foreign
countries as well and several years ago
we got into the realm of soil testing on
more recently plant tissue analysis we
also do water and manure analysis for
customers as well ergo one you might
wonder you know with all this dairy
influence how does their grow one fit
into their well in 2009 many of you are
aware that the Cornell nutrient analysis
laboratory basically discontinued their
commercial soil testing they joined
strength with with dairy one to provide
soil and plant tissue analysis services
to New York homeowners farmers and farm
advisors in this new venture called agro
one and the Cornell nutrient analysis
lab continues to conduct research
samples they also provide the the heavy
metal testing they still assemble and
sell the the pH test kits they conduct
particle size analysis and a number of
other tests as well there at the at the
lab in Ithaca they're also responsible
for the nutrient recommendations and as
part of the the air grow one agreement
we do the chemical analysis but Cornell
still generates the recommendations the
new lab director my krudsky X as the
primary liaison between Cornell and
dairy one and Steve reiners is the
primary liaison for the recommendations
so we have a very close working
relationship with the folks at Cornell
for those of you who are joining us from
New York and you need a little bit more
clarification about who's responsible
for what has already mentioned dearie
one or a grow one which I will probably
use a little bit interchangeably we're
responsible for the routine chemical
analysis of soils and plant tissue
samples we're responsible for billing
and accounts with customers the report
formats the delivery vehicles whether
it's email or fax or searchable database
for example we're also responsible for
you know if somebody's looking for a
report or they have some unexpected
results and they have some questions the
county offices are very important
because they're sort of the first level
of contact for that customer
in New York State if they need some
assistance interpreting the
recommendations as always that's that's
how it's always been and will continue
to be there also the go-to part of
Cornell if a customer has general crop
management questions or needs assistance
for example with identifying soil series
names that you need for recommendations
cnl or the cornell lab they're
responsible for overall soil testing and
plant tissue testing procedures general
questions or comments about the nutrient
guidelines any of the specialized tests
like heavy metals and also for providing
access to the commodity experts if the
county offices need additional
assistance we also a tegra one work very
closely with the Cornell soil health lab
and some of you from outside of New York
State are probably familiar with Bob
Jean de Becque and the soil health lab
they're looking at taking a more
holistic approach to soil health and
looking at chemical physical and
biological health of the soil and as you
probably know we're doing the chemical
analysis but Cornell will be doing the
physical and biological evaluations and
this list on this page shows many of the
components that Cornell is looking at in
physical and biological health and again
agri one is responsible for the the
chemical analysis is part of that
program I'm guessing that most of you if
you're working with Barry crops here in
the Northeast are in the US you
certainly understand the importance of
soil testing so i apologize if a lot of
this is a repeat but for those of you
who maybe aren't as familiar with soil
testing i just want to review as they
asked me to to review some of the
important parts of soil sampling and
soil testing and i think we all know
that it's a very important crop
management tool you really have to have
that tool to know how much lime and
fertilizer to apply to get optimum crop
yield and quality and to avoid costly
over/under fertilization of that crop
and it's also important from an
environmental perspective as well and in
in some of our crop commodities
especially in the dairy end of things a
regular soil testing program is a
requirement of many of the nutrient
management planning efforts and in most
states now when it comes to soil
sampling and analysis I'm going to be
covering a number of different topics
including establishing a sampling
schedule using the right tools including
the probes appeals the containers and
forms you wouldn't think that would be
all that important but I'll you might
learn a couple of things that about even
the sample containers that you didn't
know before sampling technique I'll
cover where weird a sample how many
subsamples sample depth preparing the
sample for shipment and then we'll do a
very brief discussion of soil test
options whether it's for routine or
diagnostic purposes and some of the
different analytical options because
there are a lot of different soil test
procedures out there in addition to the
ones that are listed here there's
actually a few others and then this as
well and I'll touch briefly on
interpretation and follow-up as well
probably the most important part of this
whole puzzle when it comes to soil
testing and soil fertility for any crop
is getting the soil pH to the right
level for optimum crop performance and
with most fruits and vegetables most
most crops in general that optimum range
is in the PH range of six to seven but
in it with berries in particular
blueberries have some different
requirements blueberries in particular
if you look at the general requirements
for berries most berries I think pretty
simple you could just say if it's a good
alfalfa soil it's going to be good for
strawberries or raspberries many of the
berry crops they need a well-drained
sandy loam soil ideally with a pH and
that's 62 to 68 range organic matter
somewhere above three percent and but
for blueberries as I've already alluded
to
crop that operates best at a pH between
4.2 and 4.8 which is much more acidic
than other berry crops also tends to do
well at slightly higher organic matters
and can perform very well even with low
phosphorus availability so that that
certainly is a important distinction to
make and it can be very crop specific
like with anything else whether we're
talking manure or forage or soil or milk
sampling technique is probably the most
important part of the whole process if
you get a crummy sample you're going to
get crummy results so it's very very
important to take time to do it right
and spend your money effectively because
that's going to determine the accuracy
and repeatability of that sample it's
good for a perennial crop like berries
you need to get that that done properly
upfront before you get the crop planted
because they it will be your last shot
for a number of years to make any major
adjustments in pH or soil nutrient
levels and again it it will help you
ultimately avoid very costly over or
under fertilization so these are all
very important considerations first we
want to establish a sampling schedule
and obviously the best time to do this
is sample before if the crop goes in the
ground although it always amazes me
whether it's seed or fertilizer whatever
how many panic questions you get after
somebody hit they put something in the
ground they don't have very good results
and then they call wondering what they
can do because they didn't check the
soil pH they didn't check the fertility
on and on so get that sample for berries
especially with blueberries at least a
year ahead of planting and in the case
of other berries probably six to twelve
months is a good idea as well because
you have to allow enough time for added
lime or sulfur to react with the soil to
give that pH down to the desired range
within the whole rooting zone of the
plant and then after that typically
recommend
and with with perennial crops to be
sampling every two to three years or as
needed for troubleshooting typically
though with with any kind of fruit we
couple the soil sampling with plant
tissue analysis because we need to know
what's what's in the soil and what's
actually getting into the plant and
that's a very useful diagnostic and when
it comes to determining fertilizer needs
for the the crop and it can also be
helpful if you're using a cover crop
between rows to make sure that you're
meeting the needs of that crop as well
and as far as time of the year I guess I
would just say that spring or fall is
probably the most logical time of year
to sample once you pick a time stick
with it so that you're sampling at the
same time in the future as well
generally considered that fall is the
most reliable time of year primarily for
soil pH determination because the soil
is a little bit moister and changes in
the summer because the soil moisture
drying out can result in a temporary
decrease in soil pH so sampling in the
summer time typically is it can be a
little bit misleading so just make sure
that you get that sample in enough time
so that you can make the proper
adjustments needed to get that pH
increased or decreased as as the soil
test requires Janet we have a question
okay sure Janet sorry we have a question
from Laura she just received a question
about buffered or unbuffered cce tests
CEC tests for pre plant cell test for
blueberries can you help her make a
recommendation the cation exchange
capacity is that what she's asking about
yes should they indicate they want the
buffered or the unbuffered test for pre
plant blueberries um i guess i would
have to defer that question to marvin
because i'm not a fruit specialist per
se and we don't do any we don't provide
cation exchange capacity as part of the
cornell packages of the the dairy one
the mail like three packages you you can
get a cation exchange capacity all of
the the CEC testing currently for the
Cornell packages would be done at CL
because it is a different procedure than
the procedure used with malik three so i
guess i'll make note of that and if you
can keep track of who we asked the
question we can make sure we can get
back to her with with an answer thank
you okay sorry I couldn't help you with
that now back to some of the tools of
the trade certainly there are a lot of
different tools out there for sampling
soils and I wish I could say that
there's one tool it's better than
another but sometimes the answer to that
is well it depends on the soil
conditions and the soil types and you
might need if you're doing a lot of soil
sampling you might want to have several
of these in your arsenal of tools and I
will review them real real quickly here
typically we would suggest that you use
a stainless steel probe or a stainless
steel auger for best results if you're
using something that's going to get
rusty then that rust can be that iron
contamination can be an issue with some
of those homemade probes especially in
high pH areas and we typically don't see
many of those issues here in New York
but in some of the western states i know
iron chlorosis is a problem on crops
like soybeans and other crops as well
and iron contamination could give you a
false high reading of iron when you
actually could be deficient so that's
why using a stainless steel probe is a
better idea and likewise if you're
mixing samples and a bucket out in the
field or or in the garage for example
don't use a galvanized pale on because
that can contaminate the sample with
zinc so it's it's best to use a clean
plastic bucket and I've already
mentioned that there are probes and
there's augers well what's the
difference well I think most of you are
probably familiar with using the slit
cited augers anybody who's doing a lot
of soil sampling would probably agree
that using one that also has a foot
peg on it is a lot easier on your back
if you're only doing an occasional
sample here there then the it foot peg
isn't as critical but certainly is it
will save your back a lot of aggravation
if you're doing a lot of sampling and
it's also going to be faster in good
conditions and it but it works the best
in a dry soil with few rocks and where I
live we have a lot of rocks and that can
plug it up and also in very wet soils
that type of a probe will just push the
sample down and it doesn't go up into
the tube so there can be a consideration
so an auger is probably a better choice
on rocky soils or on eroded Knowles if
you have a lot of like Shelly rocks flat
rocks they tend to be very troublesome
or wet soils and you even with wet soils
you'll have some of the soils sticking
to the flights on the on the auger but
it'll still work you can also use a
power drill if you're doing a lot of
samples and you can put a plastic
container like a food container with a
hole in the middle around the auger so
that the soil will fall back into that
container is it pulls the soil out of
the ground it'll help considerably you
can use shovels or spades for occasional
use or in the home garden but you need
to trim it so you're just getting like a
one-inch core down the middle otherwise
the wedge-shaped samples isn't going to
be representative you're going to get
you know maybe too much of the upper
surfaces represented and it's a lot
slower and more difficult to get a good
sample and just not practical in most
cases if you're doing a lot of sampling
and I think that we're starting to see a
lot more of the automatic samplers used
by some of the crop advisors and they're
gaining in popularity in areas where
they're using precision agriculture and
maybe they're using variable rate
application the hand probes are probably
still best for shallow samples but I
think that these automatic samplers can
be very
in untilled sites and also for deep
sampling there they can be very good as
well I'll probably see more of those out
in the field and something I learned
when I was putting this presentation
together I've used Pam or silicone
sprays on our Forge probe on the outside
of the probe to make it easier to get
that probe in and out of a ballet or a
bunk silo but you can also use them in
soil test probes on the inside on the
outside of the probe so that you can
prevent plugging and the only situation
where you wouldn't want to use something
like Pam or wd-40 or a silicone spray is
if you are doing a diagnostic sample for
a suspected micronutrient deficiency but
for your run-of-the-mill normal routine
soil test research shows that it's okay
to use these these types of products to
help prevent sticking there are a lot of
different places where you can order a
soil test probe you can even get one on
ebay or amazon com but I think most
people are familiar if you're doing any
any serious soil testing soil sampling
oakfield apparatus is one that they have
a very comprehensive assortment of soil
samplers gamblers Granger's you know
they typically handle of Oakfield and
other soil samplers been Meadows is
another supplier and you can spend
anywhere from fifty dollars up to a
thousand dollars for a standard soil
test probe or a kit so really a lot of
it depends on your personal preference
and how much you're going to be using it
for your job so it's hard for me to say
which which unit will be best for you
but there's a lot there's a lot to
choose from and if you're not sure I
guess I would start on the low end and
work your way up if you if you decide
you need something with more bells and
whistles now when we get down to actual
sampling strategies I think it just
common sense would tell you that the
more sub-samples you take
the better and typically we recommend
taking samples in a somewhat random
zigzag pattern in each management area
if you're you're bury the area that
you're planning is less than two acres
probably eight to ten subsamples in that
two acre area would be sufficient but if
you're larger than two acres I would
suggest ten to twenty subsamples and
more sub-samples is always going to be
better and with some crops usually in
larger fields some consultants are doing
grid sampling for this precision
agriculture and using those automatic
samplers but it can be very expensive
when it's done properly ideally you'd
get one sample per acre realistically
there I think most people are doing
maybe one sample for every four to five
acres and then also you might be doing a
directed sampling based on the
topography of the field and this picture
you can see in a row despite up on the
top left of the the figure or a low spot
down on the bottom right you might want
to take separate samples from you know
the main area compared to an eroded spot
or a low spot or if you're
troubleshooting you'll be taking a
targeted sample from the bed area and a
targeted sample from a good area just to
help you further pin down where the
problem might be and along those lines
with directed sampling you want to avoid
unusual areas avoid the dead furrows
farm lanes old hedgerows old manure
piles wet areas severely eroded areas
unless you're going to sample them
separately and as I mentioned before
take separate samples from areas that
vary greatly and either the slope or
texture or crop history and of course
just like with forage sampling you you
want to sample each lot of hay
differently you want to sample each
management area separately if you're
going to be fertilizing it differently
where there's a different crop
or if you have a suspected nutrient
imbalance in that area sample it
separately from the rest and I've
already alluded to this routine versus
diagnostic sampling it's a little bit
different with routine soil analysis
you're going to be looking at lime and
fertilizer recommendations for
establishment or maintenance this is
what you would be doing you know if you
don't have any specific problems or
suspected imbalances just routine for
diagnostic analysis you might want to
also add soluble salts to the standard
package with some crops if they have a
high boron requirement you might also
want to add the hot water soluble boron
is an example to the standard package
and as I also mentioned previously use
paired samples from good and bad areas
and with berries also if you're doing
some troubleshooting use a plant tissue
analysis in conjunction with soil
testing to further assist with any
troubleshooting efforts that you might
have just because something's in the
ground doesn't mean it's getting into
the plant and and then also is where the
soil health evaluations can be very
helpful because that's looking at
compaction and also biological issues
and and many other physical
characteristics of a soil that might
impact the ability of the plant a
actually take up the nutrients even if
they are they're sampling to the proper
depth certainly very important Marvin
pritts said that you know with most
berry crops surface 28 inch depth is
adequate because the rooting depth of
most berries would be in that area that
0 to 8 inches get that ahead of planning
so you can plow down and incorporate
needed lime sulfur or nutrients and same
thing for established stands sample down
to that eight inch depth but use it
along with this plant tissue analysis
now Marvin did mention that if you had a
suspected problem and
and you needed to get a deeper sample
you just need to specify on the sample
information sheet that let's say you're
sampling it at eight to sixteen inch
depth because it certainly would be
useful in interpreting that information
and using it to modify your
recommendations but that that's not a
routine requirement for for berries then
when you're out in the field taking
those samples you want to discard that
if you do have any grassy met of you
know decaying plant material on top of
the the core discard that scarred the
soil below eight inches put it in the
bucket makes it completely in a clean
plastic bucket or bag and i will say
that we get an awful lot of samples in
it egra one that are taken when the
soils are really too wet to be sampled
that makes it very difficult to mix
those subsamples up uniformly so you
probably are going to have to air dry
those samples if you want to get them
mixed well and get a good composite
sample and so really if you can't avoid
sampling under extremely wet soil
conditions it's probably a good idea for
a number of reasons they also get our
leaky you can have some changes in some
nutrients primarily when you're talking
the liked psn tea samples the nitrogen
can change very quickly especially in
what samples but it really is not
conducive to getting a good mix of all
those sub-samples when you have your
sample all air dried and and mixed up
another very important part of the
process is to complete the sample
information sheet fill in all of the
required information whether it's a soil
name the soil drainage class depending
on what state you're from and what they
require but also the billing information
who gets copies whether you want it
faxed or emailed make sure you get all
that information filled in and keep a
copy for your own record
to that that's can be invaluable if you
are looking for reports later if for
whatever reason you lost your copy or
you didn't get it whatever it just makes
tracking it down that much easier and
when all is said and done we only need
about three quarters to one point of a
mixed sample whether it's in a box or
bag so it's roughly two cups of sample
or less that that's all that we need
we're actually only going to analyze
about two grams of that sample when all
is said and done Janet we have a
sampling question yes Jeff would like to
know what you would suggest as a
sampling procedure when growers are
using drip tape for fertigation a drip
tape for fertigation well obviously
you're you're you don't want to be
sampling through the drip tape but I
guess you need to get between the rows
and just stay in the exact pattern if at
all possible and get as close to you
know Rose centers as possible I haven't
worked with with drip tape so I guess
Jeff if you have any suggestions on that
I'd appreciate I've never sampled in
that kind of a situation but you still
need to get the area where the roots are
going to be able to reach so how far
part of those those drip tapes I guess I
should i ask that right up front
yeah they do you have an answer to that
it would vary from crop to crop there
might only be one it typically would run
down the center the center well then I
would just say that you know obviously
avoid those areas because you don't want
to damage the tape and also nutrients
might be a little bit more concentrated
there and not representative of what the
whole rooting zone would be it'd be sort
of like sampling under the drip line of
trees for example you just want you want
to get in try and get samples in the
area where the crop is actually going to
be drawing its nutrients from that's
it's about all I can suggest on that one
I'll make a note on that as well and see
if Marvin has any suggestions on
sampling where there's drip tape okay
what I'm going to move on here because
we still have a fair amount to cover
here when you're getting the samples
ready you know that you've got it all
mixed up you're ready to put it in the
sample bag or box box one thing that a
lot of people aren't aware of and is
that you really should if possible use a
bag or box provided by the lab and avoid
commercial paper paper bags or paper
boxes and the reason for that is that
the glue and many paper bags and also
just the processing of cardboard there
may actually be some boron used in the
glue and in the treatment of that
cardboard and it kind of altered the
results especially if the sample is wet
so if you're if you're growing a boron
sensitive crop you could get an
artificially high reading if you're
using a commercial bag or box so that's
something that a lot of us in the soil
testing industry learned the hard way
many years ago but a lot of customers
still are not aware of that fact so keep
that in mind as well I've already
mentioned how important the paperwork is
and there is a pointer here this is an
example of the fruit form for the air
grow one samples we have a
an F form for fruits V form for
vegetables a is field crops H is the
home garden and t is for turf on all of
these except for homeowner there there
is I'm trying to get an arrow here if
you look at the middle where it says
soil information or soil name if you
want to get recommendations in New York
you have their ears that arrow how do I
move it well it I'm sorry let me back up
here getting ahead of myself under soil
name it's required with with everything
except for the home sample sheet you
must provide a valid soil name or you
will not get recommendations and most
people who have been farming for any
length of time they know they have the
maps of their fields they know the soil
names are in Vermont you we need to have
a soil drainage class and for the
homeowner samples you need to provide
some information on drexel texture and
soil drainage in order to get those
recommendations you also need to fill in
the uh non the various crops of cropping
history and what your future crops will
be in the on the vegetable forms and on
the the field crop forms and you can get
multiple year recommendations so it's
very important to read this carefully
and provide all of the required
information if you want to get the
report back the way you expect it to be
so to fill it in legibly and if you
don't know where to find your soil
series name and this is useful
information whether you're in other
states that don't require a soil name
for recommendations but there is a web
soil survey the link is provided on our
forms this it item number two web soil
survey is an NRCS website and you can go
there it's pretty user-friendly if I can
figure it out you can and you just type
in an address and zoom in on a specific
field and create a box and tell it to
map it and it will literally map all the
different soil types in it
civic field or area and provide you with
some information on the characteristics
of those soils there is also an app for
iPhones I see I have that here twice for
iPhones Androids it's from California
actually from UC Davis but it is an NRCS
based app that you can put on your
smartphone and it's georeference so if
you're standing out in the field
somewhere you just click on that app and
it'll get you the soil name and the
characteristics for the spot where
you're standing so it's that's another
very useful tool that's available for
free it's a free app so i would suggest
you try that out and as i mentioned that
web soil survey if you do use that this
map is a little bit hard to see but it
will it'll come up with a map with faint
yellow lines and then you've got the
codes of the the various soil types
within each soil unit area and then that
they'll give you a legend for the map
and there's additional information on
that web soil survey site as well as far
as the characteristics of that
particular soil as you can see there's
the you know a lot of fields have more
than one soil type the nice thing here
is that this will give you the acres of
each soil type within the the area that
you had the map so just list the one
that's the primary soil type in that
field and if it's a palmyra gravelly
silt loam for example all we need is
palmyra we don't need the descriptors at
the end just the soil series name is
sufficient to get those recommendations
and then when it comes time for shipping
and handling check with the lab that
you're working with the see what the
options are if you're working with us we
already have a built-in system of pickup
points for our milk samples wherever
there's cows there's going to be pickup
points and on our website you can go to
this map and click on the the location
nearest to you and find out the address
and the days and the time that samples
are picked up generally it's three
three times a week and there's no charge
for that so you can ship the samples
free of charge otherwise you can ship
them by US mail FedEx UPS whatever is
going to be best and for things like PS
NT that are a little bit more time
sensitive I'd suggest mailing early in
the week so that they don't sit in a
post office somewhere for a couple of
days losing time and getting warm and
changing in their their analysis so
that's basically it in terms of sampling
and shipping and handling just some
general general guidelines which would
fit whether you're working with a grow
one or you're working with a university
lab or another commercial lab and so
field sampling is field sampling but
when we get down to extraction and
chemical analysis there are quite a few
differences between labs and it's
important to understand the differences
because it there are some challenges
there's it's often tempting to compare
the results from one lab to another but
that's not always a good idea because
chances are very good they're using
different extraction techniques and the
numbers aren't going to be comparable
maybe the relative ranges are but the
extraction results the numbers can be
very different and it just makes it
rather difficult and specifically how do
these labs differ well depending on
where you from you might be using a
different extractant solutions such as
Olson or Bray or their their more
Midwest or western US procedures or a
maelich 3 or Morgan or modified Morgan
maelich 3 is used by Penn State and some
of the southern states and some of the
Midwest commercial labs as well Morgan
historically has been used by Cornell
modified Morgan is used by both agro one
it used to be used it Vermont it's
currently the the procedure used it you
may
each one of these measures a different
amount of phosphorous and potassium and
for a specific lab or a specific state
the recommendations are based on rate
response studies that have been
calibrated against the P and K soil test
for that that state or that lab and the
sufficiency values are specific to the
extractant that's used relative levels
like I said you might be a little bit
better off there but as far as the
actual absolute values of ppm of
phosphorous or potassium or pounds per
acre of phosphorous and potassium be
very specific to the extractant used as
i mentioned bray one that's one oil test
that was developed for use in the in the
north central us on acid to neutral
soils maelich three works on a broad
range of soils it's used by a lot of
commercial soil testing labs dairy one
has a male 3 package Olson is a test
that was developed for use on alkaline
soils mostly out in the western US
Morgan which is also available through
dairy one or a girl one was developed
for the acid soils here in the Northeast
and the modified Morgan is just a
modification that provides improved
micronutrient extraction the difference
between those two is a Morgan uses a
sodium acetate extraction and the
modified Morgan uses ammonium acetate
now explain a little bit more about that
in a few moments then once you get your
soil test results typically you'll see
different you might have bar graphs that
show the relative levels and on the soil
test and they're basically calibrated
you know soil test levels but on one
axis versus relative yield on the other
axis and very quite simply it's an index
of availability and crap response so
if you're in that very low too low range
on a soil test it's very likely that
you're going to your crab will respond
to added inputs of lime and fertilizer
if you're in that optimum range it's
less likely that you're going to see a
big response to fertilizer you're more
likely to be you know using maintenance
applications to keep your soil test
levels in the adoptable range and then
as you get up into the hide a very high
range it's very unlikely or less likely
certainly that you'll have any
significant response to edit fertilizer
or lime so this is basically how those
soil test interpretations are created
and in the Cornell interpretation if you
look in the Cornell field crops handbook
it basically it goes into a little bit
more detail here but basically the same
thing from very low nutrient level or pH
is sufficiently low that you really do
need extra inputs of lime or fertilizer
all the way up to excess we're very
unlikely do you have any benefit but it
is very likely to cause it to increase
the likelihood of pollution so there
they're both very important to
understand those ranges and as I
mentioned already most soil tests do not
routinely include boron boron can be
very important for some of the fruits so
you want to keep that in mind as well
and there are different tests but what
we're using is a hot water boron
analysis which is the the preferred
procedure by Cornell and it would be
consistent with these relative ranges
that you find in some of the Cornell
literature and some of the analysis
options specifically for for Agri one
just as an example you really need to
you might need to study these a little
bit because it would be easy to select
the the wrong
service and you want to make sure if you
want to get Cornell recommendations that
you select the air grow one services
with Cornell guidelines as I mentioned
before the field crops are using a
Morgan analysis everything else will be
modified Morgan fruit vegetable turf
home lawn and garden the out-of-state
soil health samples will also be run
modified Morgan and actually right now
in the arena of root of fruit if you
want to get recommendations from agri
one you really have to use one of the
the air grow one services with Cornell
guidelines you'd probably have to go
through the soil health option if you're
out of state we currently don't have
recommendations programmed in for the
air grow one services with air grow one
guidelines they're coming but we don't
have those at this time for the air grow
one services with air grow one
guidelines we we do conduct a maelich
three analysis and it's a little bit
more cost effective than Malick three
then Morgan or modified Morgan and
there's a number of reasons for that one
of which it's much less corrosive easier
tests to run less you know waste
byproducts that dispose of less
labor-intensive so that there are
reasons for the price differences on the
four Pennsylvania we offer a male like
three from Maryland they require a male
like three with fertilizer index value
which is a calculated value for New York
we can do a male at three with Morgan
equivalent values reported and for other
Northeast states we run maelich three
analysis we do on occasion get samples
from outside of the Northeast in which
case we will run a maelich three with
generic recommendations that are maybe
not state specific if we got something
from Colorado we don't have
recommendations for Colorado so they
would be more generic northeast
recommendations so
keep that in mind if you wanted to send
samples to dairy one for example and
then we also run a modified Morgan for
Vermont and there is a difference I know
this sounds confusing but there are some
minor differences between the
requirements the modified Morgan
procedures for Vermont and New York and
Maude and Vermont we use a ICP
phosphorus which is just a ICP as the
piece of equipment that we use to
extract and determine the nutrients in
New York we use a modified Morgan but we
do a color metric phosphorus just a
minor difference but it's a different
requirement according to the state
specifications and there are other labs
in the Northeast it offers similar
services as i mentioned main does a
modified morgan penn state as a maelich
three and there are other commercial
labs that that do a lot of business in
the Northeast and over the US who offer
various services so you just need to
check with them but just remember don't
use test results from one lab or a
procedure from one lab and compare it
with sufficiency ranges from another lab
or another procedure you need to keep
that in mind and just as an example here
in New York and in our services for
example a male 3 versus a Morgan you
might wonder well you know how different
could they be well with a male like
three is going to extract potentially
anywhere from 30 to 300 times more
phosphorus at high aluminum oil levels
at low ph s and it will express extract
less phosphorus at a high pH or low
aluminum so that's very different and so
if you're comparing me a mail like three
that you did last year with a Morgan
that you're doing this year you could
get very different numbers the modified
Morgan versus Morgan they're pretty
comparable overall but you will see
difference on potassium values on some
soils the ammonium acetate and modified
Morgan
that ammonium ion is smaller than sodium
in the the Morgan extractant and it'll
push that potassium that's trapped
between clay particles in the LA elight
clay parent material in some New York
soils so it'll push more that that
potassium out into the soil solution so
it'll give a higher potassium number
than a Morgan extractant would otherwise
they're they're quite comparable so
which lab should you use well I guess
you should you should use a lab that
offers procedures and nutrient
guidelines that are appropriate for your
region and for your soils don't use test
results from one labor procedure and
sufficiency ranges from another lab or
procedure as I've already explained they
can get you in trouble and get you very
confused use caution even when you're
comparing one lab to another even when
they're using the same extractant
because there can be some lab to lab
variability for the same procedure some
might way the sample others might use a
scoop some might use ICP phosphorus
versus color metric phosphorus the soil
the solution ratio might be a little
different or the shaking time might be a
little different and all of these subtle
differences even the grinder that they
use to grind the dried sample can be a
little bit different and all of these
subtle differences can result in some
variability that's that they can be
confusing so stick with the same lab if
possible once you find when you're
comfortable with and be careful when
you're comparing one lab to another the
report this is just a sample of our
fruit report up towards the the the top
you'll see the the results reported in
pounds per acre but then you'll have the
relative sufficiency levels the very low
low optimum high or very high below that
you'll have some of the other
measurements such as pH or buffer ph
which is used to determine your lime
requirement and you'll also see down
below the the micronutrients that are
included in the standard package
including manganese
he's in zinc and iron and we also
provide organic matter and then farther
down below that you'll see the actual
fertilizer recommendations in this case
it was a Apple report I should have
pulled up a blueberry or a berry report
but this will give you the the pounds
per acre of lime and the pounds per acre
of n p 2 o 5 and k2 oh that's required
to bring that crop or that soil into the
appropriate balance now I would say with
with apples we do have a surface and
subsurface option with apples and if you
do have a paired sample for a surface
which would be 0 to 8 and subsurface
which is 8 to 16 you need to indicate
that they're paired samples and that is
used in generating one recommendation
based on the paired samples but that's
only true of tree fruits not berries and
just finally in summary I think we all
know soil testing is is very important
part of the whole process if you have to
want to optimize yield and quality of
berries and avoid issues with a runoff
into groundwater or runoff into bodies
of water like any other analytical
service it's garbage in garbage out or
quality and quality out so you've got to
get a good sample upfront and follow
some of the basic guidelines that I
provided relative to establishing a
sampling schedule using the right tools
sampling at the right depth taking
enough sub-samples and prepping that
sample properly to get a good
representative composite sample in
appropriate boxes or bags from the lab
and then to select the appropriate
service whether you're using a routine
or a diagnostic service and select the
appropriate extractant whether it's
morgan modified Morgan or maelich three
and you know what the lab has to offer
and and then following up
every two to three years preferably with
tissue analysis in the case of berries
and I know I covered a lot a lot of it
was probably a review if you do have any
other questions you can go to our
website at ww.com or you can email me at
Janet Fallon at Dairy 1.com and there is
one mistake on that hit slide I'm just
seeing my cell phone number is no longer
the one that's on the screen so write
this down if you do have a question for
me my cell phone number is now 3 15 6960
167 if you have any questions I'd be
happy to answer those for you and if I
don't have an answer I can certainly get
one from from Marvin and get back to you
promptly so that's pretty much it Cathy
I know we're getting close on time here
so if we have any other questions I'll
try and answer them do we have any
questions Mariana has a question I have
several growers wanting to grow organic
are there any recommendations for
organic growers or a way to convert the
recommendations that are given that's a
good question basically a soil test
really isn't going to differentiate
between an organic or so-called
conventional operation because the crop
nutrient requirements will be the same
regardless it's all in the
interpretation and I do know that
Cornell has been working very diligently
at coming up with some updated
guidelines for using organic fertilizer
sources of crop nutrients and as soon as
those are available from Cornell they
would be incorporated into the
recommendations but basically we're just
giving recommendation on pounds of n P
and K to apply to a crop to bring that
to a soil to bring it into balance it's
really up to the operator to meet the
is needs with whatever source of
nutrients they choose to use whether
it's organic and and certainly with
organic it's very different because you
tend to be using more organic excuse me
um well yeah not synthetic chemicals but
organic that may be slower in releasing
nutrients so it's I think using that
soil health program I think is is
probably going to be a good way to
address that issue for the organic
growers because it does address the the
physical and biological health of the
soil as well and there are a number of
resources listed on both the air grow
one link and also on the Cornell links
that would would send you to information
on some of the organic amendments for
meeting crop nutrient requirements so
that's it's sort of a yes and no a soil
test doesn't differentiate between the
two okay we have a question from Glen
how long does lime correction of pH
typically laughs before real iming is
needed well again that one is going to
depend a lot on a number of things
including soil texture the parent
material the soil and how much nitrogen
you're applying or other acidifying
fertilizers it because it you know if
you're applying large amounts of
nitrogen for example that's going to
bring the ph down faster if a soul has a
high buffer capacity it's going to
resist changes in pH up or down more so
you might hold that pH longer once you
get it up to the desired pH if you have
a real sandy soil with a low cation
exchange capacity for example that soil
pH may change more rapidly so a lot of
it is going to depend on on the soil
resource that you're working with and
there's a comment from Marvin that the
end raise production guides provide
tables with organic nutrient sources and
you can use those to calculate how much
of an organic source you need based on
the soil test
dation Bob also has a question he's
wondering if you are Marvin could talk
more about the Cornell soil health test
and how they if they've been used for
Barry crops
I know that that Bob Shindo vet Beck has
been working very extensively with
vegetable and fruit growers but I really
haven't been privy to you know who and
what the results have been on that maybe
Marvin can type in some some comments on
that as well but it is something that
they are targeting the higher value
crops especially such as the fruits and
vegetables simply the testing is a bit
more costly than standard soil testing
as you would imagine and on high viu
crops it certainly is is worthwhile
because it's a long-term investment to
get that crap established and keep it
productive Laura McDermott is commented
that she's used Cornell so health test
with Barry crops and one of the purposes
of this project in year two when we
involve the growers is to help build
that database for Bob Shindo back and
for held vaness and so we have 50
growers that are going to get
complimentary soil health testing so
that we can start to do that well one
thing I would like to just add is that
we do have a number of extension
educators in New York who are currently
set up on our searchable database and
they can go online right now and search
by farmer by date by county for example
for soil tests and also by crop
commodity whether it's fruit or
vegetable or field crops and I believe
sometime around November one we should
be launching that service to all of our
customers who have an account so if
you're an Extension educator check out
our website here in the next month or so
and there should be some guidelines on
how to get assigned a username and a
password and will be planning a little
webinar to walk people through the
process of how to find their soil test
reports and then you can
so download some of that information
into tables or spreadsheet so you can
compare trends over time maybe obviously
you won't have any history the first
time you start using us but after a
number of years and a number of cycles
soil testing you'd have some comparative
information or if you want to do county
summaries for example that's another
good use for the searchable database
Marvin did have a comment also that
we're just starting to use soil health
test for berries we don't have major
results yet the vegetable growers are
out in front on this and we also have a
question from Jeff are there any studies
on the intensity of soil sampling and
the repeatability of results in small
fruit production I have a feeling that
Marvin has an answer to that one too and
I have to believe that there are I know
there's been a lot of work done with
grid sampling and intensity of soil
sampling and repeatability I've seen it
with with field crops Marvin I see he's
typing frantically here I would have to
guess that they has also been done for
for berries but I'm not the person to
ask sorry that's okay well we're waiting
for Marvin to type in his comments will
go to the exit screen and let's see so
he says the greatest source of
variability is in the sampling not in
the testing procedure okay if anyone
else has questions be sure to type them
into the chat box any while thank you
very much Janet for a
go ahead oh I just wanted to thank you
for an excellent webinar we really
appreciated your input and I wanted to
announce that the next webinar is the
11th of November and dr. Marvin Pritts
is going to be our speaker the topic
will be interpretation of soil test
results prior to planting again if you
haven't completed the demographics
questionnaire or the educator pretest
you can download those janet has
provided a PDF file on sampling which
you're welcome to download also the agri
one link is on the left and I just
wanted participants to know that upon
completion of the webinar series you
will receive a certificate indicating
your achievement are there any other
questions
well thank you everybody thanks Janet
alright then thanks everyone for joining
us today and we'll see you again on the
fourth of November
you
you
Oh